Arghhhhaa......
oh my oh my god
is it
time
another v
another video
I thought I could cure him
By getting rid of his forehead... BUT ITS NOT ENOUGH
If I can beat this game,
if I could beat this game
Ainsley will LIVE.
(sad music starts)
But if I can't
we'll see each other in Nangiala :_-(
wait I did not agree to this
you barbarian
♪ It's been a long day♪
♪without you my friend... ♪
♪ And I'll tell you all about it ♪
♪ when I see you again... ♪
pewds: when I see you again
ooohhhhhhhhh
ah okay
here we go
so far
we're doing great ainsley
still alive
still breathing
but we gotta be ready for an attack
at any point
Wait! stopstopstopstopstopstop- Pewds: WHAT.
wait stopstopstop stop
angry pewds:WHAT
Alright, um...no...you do not go there
no ugh
you do not go there
you go left
You go left...yes um
yes umm
ugh turns out no
you go left now
you are going left
screw that direction
moving left now
ok
umm....that's a death there
why??
well I guess our hero.....
Oh my god you just died
Oh thats uh... It happens to the best of us
I don't see the fucking point.
Like, you can't just randomly kill-
O.N: You died! Congrats Hero!
What killed me?!
What was that?!
O.N: Oh, I see you're playing this game again.
Hm. Alright then. Well I guess we'll start from the drill again.
Our hero awakens unde-
ALRIGHT. Death number "whatever", Moving on.
UGH -.-
Don't- Ssh.
(sad music again)
So the apple is- uh-
its the fucking apple
What about the other one?
I don't tru- *BURP*
I don't trust anything now
Hey look-
O.N: Man I haven't seen this many strokes of death since my last time masturbating
P: Oh my god
*phew*:3
I'm doing good
I have not raged yet, so far I have not raged.^^
I have not raged yet
So far I have not Raged...
O.N: Oh I see you're playing again.
Oh i see you're pl - SHUTUP
Pewds: shut up!
O.N: hmm..
Pewds: shut! ):<
~~Pewds lost his s***~~
Pewds: ssh! ):<
O.N: It turns out..
F#%k you!! ):<
[...]O.N:dead wrong
[...]Pewds: THIS, F#%KING, BRIDGE, BETTER, NOT, FALL, ON, ME! ):<
[...] O.N: uhm so.. definitely go left..
[...] pewds: yes!:D
pewds: Okay let's..
O.N: totally the direction.. *mumble mumble*
pewds: shu.. shut up! [4x]
shut the f#%k up![2x]
*Obnoxious Narrator still mumbling*
*poods repeadly telling the Obnoxious Narrator to shut the hell up!*
*sad music starts to play*
*poods and obnoxious narrator still doing the same*
Ainsley: I think this asshole is going to kill me..)':
O.N: ugh a new story..
pewds: not the whole thing.. not the whole thing! Not the whole thing! ):<
Please not the whole thing..*dying inside*
O.N: Alright, a hero uh.. that's another death:D
O.N: well I guess our hero wakens in an open field or whatever..[fades away]
[sad music starts playing]
*Insert bang sound effect*
O.N: Oh I see you're playing this game again..
O.N: hmm..
O.N: Alright then..
pewds: I'm soo.. I don't even wanna talk..):< [O.N. mumbles on]
I'm just F#%KING PISSED!):<
pewds: annoyed.. -.-
[...] O.N: open field under an apple tree.
[...] O.N: Actually goddamned you have to go left!
pewds: watch out for that f#%king cloud for some reason..-.-
O.N: maybe you were supposed to go.. oh my god.. this is just getting sad now..)':
pewds: WHAT HAPPENED?! o:
WHATHAPPENED?!?!? =.=
f#%k you mayn.. oh no Ainsley
I'm sorry, I'm so sorry please
We're great, we're doing great..^^
top A, top o- top class
O.N: Alright, our hero awakens in an open field under an a-
(metal clank)
O.N: Alright you are not playing the game anymore, you're just dying now..(:
pewds: uughh!
O.N: yeah just keep and you sh-
[dramatic music fades in]
O.N: oooh...
pewds: okay, watch out!
[...] O.N: it looks like that's a dead end..
[...] pewds: and then f#%k the cloud!!
[...] O.N: maybe you were supposed to go right after all..
[...] pewds: how do I get past- =.=
[...] O.N: maybe I was..
[...] pewds: f#%k you cloud!(:<
O.N: maybe it wa-
[...] pewds: just shut up! [2x]
just..-  =.=
[...] O.N: well let's just think there, WHILE YOU'RE WALKING RIGHT!!
pewds: okay.. .-.
now then..(:
[complete utter silence except for in-game music and sound effect in the game..]
What do I do ?.?
(metal clank)
oh my god.. (I'm dying send help)
[ear rape!!!!]
pewds: Hey how's it going.. uhm.. jackspidecy here uhm..
Great.. great video, this has been..
I hope you've in- [...] having [...] I hope [...] I hope your..
..having
oOh!
we're filming.. we're filming it like this now.. this is.. this is..(:
[poods has dieded inside now..]
This is how I do my videos now(:
(metal clank)
okay, so now..
*burbs*
there's the apple alright?! so how do I dodge the f#%king apple?!):<
O.N: No amount of queen refrences will save you now
Please for the love of god..
listen[2x] you're not a f#%king
British person I can here you. You're just an American cunt,
who's trying to be funny and witty, but you're just f#%king annoying..
okay? alright..
just shut up[2x]
[...]O.N: Actually goddamned it
[...] pewds: Why do I have to hear the same f#%king thing
[pewds saying: over and over unlimited times]
[...] pewds: 24 f#%king times..):<
I just don't see the *idea*?
Like let me just replay it, but I've got to listen to him
every f#%king time, Jesus f#%king Christ! =.=
just shut up!! )':<
shut up! )':<
oOh boy, oh boy, uuh..
why?! okay.. I need to just..
I need to just focus[2x] :3
[up-beat music plays]
Okay, I can do this!:D
[...] O.N: Do you remember you can use WASD
[...] pewds: I'm just not gonna speak! I'm just gonna..[dies in-game]
pewds: FOCUS!
[up-beat music takes over all the sounds]
okay, wuh- we- we're getting somewhere:D
[...]O.N: Our hero passes a sign that says uhm..
[...] pewds: we did it! o:
okay..
uhh my god.. for f#%ks sake why.. .-.
why, just whu..
*snorts*
O.N: Our hero passes, there is a cl-
[...] How do I get pass that ?.?
[...]O.N: looks like our hero has passed a sign that I believed was uh..
[...] pewds: oh my god!
[...] O.N: is uhm.. wait[3x] hold on[2x]
O.N: I can read, I can, I can do this. uhm..
(metal clank)
O.N: uhm, uuhm..
O.N: read th-
[...] pewds: wooah!!! o:
wuaaah!
[...]O.N: I can read this
[...] pewds: NO! NO! ):<
f#%k you mayn, f#%k you! got'em! (:<
Give me a gun, give me a f#%king gun! I'll kill
I'll kill'em
[...] O.N: Okay yes! that's what is says
[...] pewds: good game!
No! we're not going- get the money..):<
[sad music plays]
Oh my god, I wanna die in my ass..*sounds nice*
Ey I dunno, why am I here?
Why am I here? I don't unders- I don't unders- I don't understand.. /:
I'm not good at games! ):<
This is not my kind of game -.-
alright.
wow.. [ he says very enthusiastically]
[poods making weird sounds into the microphone] (choking on that microphne if you know what I mean ;)
[sad music plays]
[...] O.N: Out of all the deaths-
[sad music plays again] )':
O.N: there's
[poods grunts out of annoyance]
[sad music plays yet again..]
Okay I just gotta be fast!
[repeats just gotta be fast]
pewds: shut the f#- shut the fu- shut! shut! shut!
Okay yeah it's great yeah, aah! hilarious
okay I got' that's so funny and the guy keeps f#%king talking!
no matter f#%king what! and it's just kinda f#%king annoying me
at this point. -.-
okay, here we go!
[...] O.N: Watch this!
[...] pewds: No! Not gonna watch shit!
what the fuck just happened?!
I'm alive![2x]
I'm- I'm breathin'- I'm alive!
APPLE!!
[sad music plays]
pewds: f#%king apple ):<
THIS IS IT[2x] THIS IS HOW YOU DIE!
THAT'S HOW IT'S DONE! ):<
[sad music continues]
*It's been a loooong daaay without you my friend*
*And I'll tell you all about it when I see you again*
*We've come a looong waay, from where we began!*
*Oh I'll tell you all about it when I see you again! When I see you again*
*When I see you agaaain! OOOOOoOOOOo! uuuUU!*
pewds: what's tha-
Made in Wall Street Journal
Wow! What a clever joke!:3 *hehe* *brofist!*